well he pushed on the progressive
prosecutors that are for example here in
new york city saying that things like
using taking a gun into a store robbing
it but then leaving and nobody gets
killed that that's a misdemeanor is the
president okay with that
well look the president's not going to
wade into the actions of prosecutors or
of the legal justice department that's
his bottom line but he's also been very
clear he's been a longtime supporter of
cops programs of the police of local
first responders of local law
enforcement and he has been an advocate
for additional funding
for additional funding
the white house refusing to call out
radical das as cities across the country
are being rocked by rising crime and
senseless violence police arresting the
career criminal they say stabbed ucla
grad student brianna cooper to death
inside a high-end furniture store
suspect sean lavalle smith was finally
arrested at a bus stop and big surprise
he has a ridiculously long rap sheet
filled with dozens of crimes in three
states and at the time of the murder he
was free on a one thousand dollar bond
and a heinous crime in new york where an
11 month old baby girl was hit in the
face by a stray bullet she is in
critical but stable condition local
leaders in both states venting their
fury over what is happening
does it matter to me
if it's a police officer shot
or if it's a baby shot
i'm going to stay in these streets
until this city is safe
i'm not going to surrender
this city to violence
we have an open-air mental asylum he was
arrested possibly for possession of
stolen items used to be a felony now a
misdemeanor got out on a ticket in
october and
just a few months later he's killing uh
uh brianna
so dana i was so grateful that you asked
jens hockey that question because crime
affects so many people around the
country and is getting worse but her
answer is doesn't really work in terms
of solving the problem you can support
the police but if the system doesn't
work together with the prosecutors to
have charges and keep these guys in jail
they get out and murder young women
while they're at work so from her
perspective right so this this is
apparently this is the president's
position this is what she's told he's
she he has told her and that's going to
be his position i think it's untenable
for two reasons both political and also
policy first on the policy side of
things uh the white house absolutely
does set a tone and an agenda for what
is prosecutorial um
emphasis like what do you want to
emphasize what you care about most and
that can trickle down to the attorney
general and others also they'll weigh in
on lots of other things that have
nothing to do with the federal
government on local issues why not this
one
and then you have the real very real
issue that americans are showing concern
about crime in the top five issues
that they're worried about and when you
have over a third just a third of the
country saying that the white house
understands problems that they're
worried about
uh
that becomes untenable from a political
standpoint
because republicans are going to be
talking about crime because that's what
people care about and because it needs
to be talked about so it's untenable
that the democrats are just going to say
oh this is just a local issue and walk
away because everybody can draw a
straight line from
democratic donors to these progressive
district attorneys and everyone's
starting to get a real clear sense as to
what the outcome is of that you had
today guess what right before we came on
the air the new district attorney here
in new york attorney uh
bragg he said disavowing the memo that
he wrote the other day didn't want
people to misunderstand what he meant
trying to withdrawing it
but people have already resigned over it
and they elected him so it is having an
impact i think it's untenable from a
policy standpoint and a political
standpoint and we'll see how long their
silence lasts
so geraldo uh jensaki says that joe
biden doesn't want to wade into justice
department issues but the justice
department has a role to play when it
comes to federal gun charges when it
comes to other federal crimes that these
guys are committing
under attorney general bill barr he
launched operation legend to deal with
precisely this rise in crime so why
isn't the president engaging the justice
department to clean up the streets
because
they harp katie
obsessed over this phony voting rights
bill invoking the language of the civil
rights movement to get a bill passed
that would allow people to vote without
id and with unrestricted mail-in ballots
so let's talk about that stuff rather
than what people are really concerned
about there were six kids shot in
chicago on tuesday on tuesdays six kids
were shot you got the you know a lady
the asian lady pushed on the tracks you
got brianna in los angeles knifed to
death by a guy on out on low bail i mean
we know if if donald trump had focused
intensely on that and not gone drifting
off about the election being fixed and
all the rest of that he would be
president today people care about this
the first role of government is to keep
people safe this is the civil rights
issue of our time how many times do i
have to say it black on black crime
that's who's killing everybody
it's the minority people are or there's
a there's a ghetto civil war going on
and we're too politically correct to
admit it you know i'm a street guy i've
been around new york a long long time
you know i'm not afraid to say this
stuff but where where is biden why
doesn't he say it the democrats in these
cities should pick up the mantle there
has never been a successful reformist
prosecutor ever ever ever ever never did
leniency lead to safety it's not it's
not going to happen you need stop and
frisk you need aggressive policing you
need the police to feel that they are
supported by the public
yeah so greg the reason joe biden's not
going after these da's or saying
anything about it it's because he would
have to confront this leftist ideology
that some of this crime is okay because
it serves a purpose of social justice in
a way that the left wants yeah and and
uh the the victimization or the death is
merely just some kind of collateral to
this radical remaking of society
and and
to your point i hate saying that but i
did um
the re they don't want to talk about
violent crime because it's on them
uh when you're talking about the
radicals that's their side so to
paraphrase joe biden they're on the
wrong side
they're on the wrong they're on the side
of the criminals as long as they support
progressive policies this is only going
to get worse but they can't switch sides
because then they're on our side and
they don't want to be on our side
geraldo is right you know
we've learned that politic most
politicians they can't do two things
right so when they're like they're
obsessed with impeachment you know covet
just takes off it was the same month and
now what they're doing is they have
obsessed over this this sham of a voting
bill again geraldo is right on that when
in when in fact you have crime exploding
nobody at home last night cared about
the voting bill or russia they wanted to
hear about kill the deaths how you were
going to fight this weird explosion in
crime they can't do woke politics and
fight crime because
politics is antithetical to crime it is
it is um to fighting crime it believes
that the criminal is in fact a victim to
a larger society and that we are in fact
the oppressors so it will never change
until the democratic party learns to
deal with this toxin in their own group
yep jesse
well if greg said they don't want to be
seen as publicly on the side of law and
order republicans they can call these
da's on the phone
they could have a nice private
conversation joe biden and
krasner and garcon and bragg and say
guys
not only are people getting killed
you're killing my popularity this crime
wave is killing me politically so
tighten it up and we'll get this thing
under control these das have political
aspirations they don't want the
president united states on their bad
side they'll tighten things up everybody
works the phones if you're the president
lbj
bush41 trump famously would burn up the
phones talking to party allies either
just shooting the breeze talking shopper
you know talking politics
barack obama used to hop on the phone
with kamala harris when she was the a.g
of california and talk all the time he
actually did say that she was the best
looking attorney general in the country
so maybe that did cross the line with
michelle but he's not prejudicing or
proceeding or giving one side a tactical
advantage in a case by calling a
district attorney that's like a fake
ethical straw man they're just throwing
up so they don't have to dive into this
thing i went out on the streets to shoot
a package for prime time which you can
see on the little bottom right of your
screen for monday
everyone i talked to when i said what do
you wanted me to cover on prime time
they said crime every race creator color
said i want you to talk about crime and
the problem with joe biden he's not
tapped in to the emotional current of
this country imagine trump's president
and they have like these high-profile
homicides people being pushed to death
in a subway in new york or in l.a
getting slashed enough the two biggest
cities in the country back to back crime
like that
trump would be out there holding a press
conference he'd be calling their parents
on the phone and biden is just yeah out
of touch hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else